le dernier débat entre donald trump et
joe biden avant l'élection du 3 novembre
sinon dans quelques heures il est
organisé à la belle montre university de
nashville dans le tennessee et s'annonce
à nouveau explosif durant 80 minutes
alors que le candidat démocrate fait la
course en tête dans les sondages le
président américain tente de bousculer
son adversaire sur le terrain alors les
dés sont ils jetés
ce dernier débat sera-t-il décisif c'est
l'objet de notre face à face et pour
débattre ce soir avec nous et yannick
mireur politologue spécialiste des états
unis bonsoir à vos côtés paul rinne
président de république and in france
messieurs bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors donald trump et joe
biden vont donc croisé le fer pendant 90
minutes
dans quelques heures et les sondages
donnent joe biden gagnant pour le moment
mais on a en tête un la défaite
d'hillary clinton en 2016
yannick mireur ce débat il est décisif
où les dés sont jetés selon vous je ne
pense pas que le débat soit décisif les
débats ne le sont pas d'ailleurs mais
disons que le ton a été donné dès le ton
moins décisif que le ton avait été donné
pour les précédents rendez-vous d'une
part d'autre part compte tenu des
comptes circonstances c'est un débat qui
arrive très près du scrutin
et à ce stade il n'y a pas de changement
majeur observé sur la vence du candidat
démocrate y compris dans les fameux
états pivots donc tout laisse penser que
cette avance devrait se maintenir tout
simplement un élément d'appréciation
supplémentaire et qui est au fond de la
question sur la personnalité du candidat
démocrate puisqu'on connaissait déjà
évidemment celle du président sortant
qui est là depuis quatre ans c'est que
lui-même s'identifie par sa trajectoire
personnelle et ses origines sociales aux
états unis à ces fameux état pivot soit
en particulier de la ceinture industriel
je veux dire le michigan la pennsylvanie
où nenê weyer le whisky signer toute
cette région du centre nord centre des
états unis et à ses électeurs qui sont
généralement des pros beaucoup des cols
bleus qui avaient l'habitude de voter
traditionnellement démocrate exception
précédente où le vote a été en faveur
des républicains allaient lui
ronald reagan cet événement la serre aux
produits à la surprise générale
d'ailleurs évidemment lors de l'élection
en 2016 de monsieur le trump face à une
hillary clinton toutefois qu'ils étaient
identifiés par sceller par cet électorat
là comme l'élite démocrate qui avait un
petit peu abandonné la cause des couches
populaires auxquels s'identifient plus
facilement joe biden boylan éléments
d'appréciation qui permet de penser que
cette avance se maintient dans ces états
les enfin comme vous le savez l'élection
américaine est assez compliquée avec le
système des grands électeurs
voilà c'est l'écart dans les sondages
donnant perdant votre candidat est ce
que malgré tout il vous inquiète
on n'a pas de tout venant on est très
confiants on a beaucoup confiance que
les bains il m'a fait bien ce soir et va
gagner l'élection les sondages sont pas
corrects et à ninon silence majoritaire
aux états unis et les les
côté républicain on voit l'entousiasme
pour ce soir j'espère que le modérateur
va enfin poser les questions
joe bind
que vous étiez en train de déjà de
parler de mes problèmes de son fils d
action complètement scandaleux que
finalement on a ses preuves grâce à son
portable ordinateur portable et vingt
trente et un millier de zimmer qui
manque de preuves qu'il a pris des des
millions d'agents de les gouvernements
étrangers qui est compris la chine
l'ukraine est en plus des gens en russe
et le midi les gros scandales et le midi
aux etats unis et le milieu socio bloc
ces informations 2 le peuple américain
ça c'est une attaque sur le liberté
d'expression aux états unis donc c'est
pour vraiment se précédement de
l'actrice a posé la question aux jo
bague assez de lui tenir responsable
pour les actions de son fils quand il
était vice-président et
jusqu'aujourd'hui
drogba n'a toujours dit que c'est pas
vrai c'est le dessin formation de la
russe évidemment encore qui est
complètement mon change donc ça ça
j'espère que ça sera le feu d'artifice
il n'y a ni que millau à ce que donald
trump ce soir dans sa stratégie
il a justement intérêt à mettre ce
dossier sur la table ce dossier donald
trump qui dénonce des prétendues
malversations financières du fils de joe
biden en ukraine et en chine vous nous
en parliez à l'instant pèlerine c'est
une stratégie qu'il a intérêt à adopter
selon vous yannick mireur comment bien
de l'entendre
je crois que le camp démocrate s'y
attend il s'attend les attaques qui
serait personnelles telles que monsieur
ring bien décrire ce qui permettrait
ceci étant dit ne pas être
nécessairement très adroit parce que je
ne pense pas que ce qu'une majorité de
l'électeur américain attend et ce qui
permettrait à son adversaire de lui
renvoyer si je puis dire en face ses
propres relations avec l'ukraine et les
pressions qu'on peut être exercée
notamment autour de cette question du
fils de monsieur byden donc ce serait un
petit peu là il pourrait y dent pour
dent dans toutes les manières le camp
démocrate
chacun se prépare un en fonction du
caractère des armes généralement utilisé
par l'autre si je puis dire avec c'est
toujours assez brune mais disons que
avec un personnage hors classe qui n'est
pas un homme politique traditionnelle
comme monsieur trump que rien n'arrête
évidemment tout est possible je ne crois
pas sur le fond j'y reviens quand même
n'est que si le destin est parti
républicain devait reposer du sur les
attaques comme celle là a continué à
tirer par le bas le débat public aux
états unis et l'esprit public à vie lit
depuis les quatre dernières années et
depuis même plus longtemps que ça mais
disons qui a particulièrement souffert
depuis les quatre dernières années mais
se disant ça ne veux pas préjuger de
l'appartenance politique du président
sortant mais plus qu'à était démocrate
car avant d'être républicain monsieur
trucks a été démocrates à new york
donc c'est plus sa personnalité et puis
pose problème si le parti républicain
qui était en lambeaux
aujourd'hui en termes de projets de
cohérence de consistance de capacité à
élever le débat zaveck mocratie
américaine ça veut pas dire que le parti
démocrate très bonne forme non plus mais
s'il ya un parti dans cet état n'a pour
se sauver
khattak et le pauvre fils de monsieur
biden je crains que ça ne passe pas ses
affaires pauline qu'est ce que vous
répondez à yannick mireur est ce que
vous pensez effectivement que donald
trump a plutôt intérêt à s'emparer
d'autres sujets comme le col la crise du
corps un avion us par exemple à ce qu'il
n'y serait pas gagnant finalement bon
c'est pas à tenir de bas
quand quelqu'un comme chambre et ses
idées exposées de corruption de son 1 le
candidat jo bad john payne était protégé
par tous les médias américains
jusqu'aujourd'hui donc ces deux
ordonnance rend malheureusement parce
que le milieu ne prend pas le rôle est
donc celle euros de dons seront pas
exposés la corruption c'est en fait
vraiment blanchiment d'argent par la
famille by day mais j'espère qu'il y
aura le temps de de revenir sur tous et
ses réussites pendant les trois ans
avant le covan et même après il a
effectivement bien pour les peuples
demain qu'un pour l'économie et tous et
mais il n'a pas le droit de parler des
affaires étrangères ce soir donc
l'organisation qui a organisé ce débat a
déjà décidé qu'il peut pas parler de ça
même que énormément de réussite même que
drogba n'a rien à dire je suis ici sur
les affaires étrangères on verra combien
fois dans le microphone de chang sera
coupée par la modératrice donc ça c'est
très intéressant mais j'espère que eelv
a fait du bien et je suis sûr que même
même que s'il fait bien ou pas bien ça
ne va pas changer énormément de choses
si yannick mireur est ce qu'il est il
est bâillonnée donald trump à la fois
par les médias par les organisateurs du
débat comme on vient nous le faire
entendre pèlerine selon vous
non non je comprends parfaitement la
position de monsieur monsieur ries ne
vais pas débattre moi je ne suis pas
américain je ne vote pas aux états unis
donc j'essaie d'apporter un oeil
extérieur et
simplement d'observer que je suis pas
certain que ce bâillonnement etc
cette description soit comme les il y à
des médias qui sont à l'évidence
ostensiblement contre monsieur tremble
encore une fois je pense que c'est une
situation particulière c'est moins le
parti républicain dans son histoire qui
est en question qu'une personnalité très
singulière de la vie publique aux etats
unis puisque avant d'être un homme
politique mais se trompe était déjà une
personnalité célèbre aux états unis avec
tout le soufre qui l'a entouré donc rien
de nouveau là dessus en revanche bon
cette approche qui consiste à dénoncer
avant d'un côté c'est une tactique qui a
choisi le parti républicain
je ne suis pas certain que ce soit bien
fondées mais c'est pas à moi de juger de
la stratégie des républicains et de
monsieur tron qui quand même assez
habile en général pour dire ce qu'il a à
dire été lancée avant des défauts d'un
adversaire qui réelle ou supposée
voilà ce qui en revanche je maintiens
quand même le fait que et j'espère en
effet monsieur rinke il sera possible de
parler d'autre chose n'est que de la
sphère du fils byden et qu'abidal lui ne
parlera pas seulement des turpitudes
ukrainienne supposé de monsieur trump
qui pourront parler en effet d'économie
de crise sanitaire d'emplois et de
medicare medicaid la sécurité sociale
et tous ces sujets qui intéressent sans
doute beaucoup plus une majorité
d'américains
car au fond je pense que s'il devait y
avoir un long détour pendant ce débat
sur le fils de monsieur byden ça
intéressera surtout une base déjà
acquise à monsieur trompe mais ne lui
permettra pas de gagner des voix dont il
a besoin
parmi des gens plus indépendants ou
disons
plus centristes et qui n'ont pas encore
fait leur choix
car là toute la difficulté de cette
élection c'est aussi qu' une grande
partie des votes un nombre substantiel
par correspondance a déjà eu lieu ce qui
est assez unique aussi dans l'histoire
des élections américaines
justement pèlerine il doit effectivement
changé sa posture ce soit donald trump
pour aller chercher un à un et victor a
encore indécis aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
beaucoup à un décideur j2ee à deux camps
et c'est bien si la chance de parler de
ce que tu sais réussite il a fait
tellement de chose de bien pour tous les
peuples en a qu'un pas que des blanches
mais plutôt pour les minorités il a fait
beaucoup plus pour les africains que joe
breen a fait en tout ça tout ça carrière
j'espère qu'il y aura autant de parler
de tout ça mais je parle de cette
histoire de joe le fils de john dryden
parce que c'est la dernière histoire
c'est c'était de cette année suivant
cette semaine que sa sortie que ses ex
collègues de son entreprise une
vastitude a dit que tu t'étais vrai
qu'ils étaient les témoins ça c'était
nouveau
dès hier donc ça c'est pourquoi c'est
intéressant que les américains de preuve
le mans qui en voudraient voir ce qui ce
toit discuter et voir les réponses de
jupp heynckes évidemment il va dire que
c'est pas vrai c'est à cause d'eux les
russes de ces informations
et ça c'est très important et ses
critiques cette histoire de corruption
yannick mireur pour conclure on l'entend
dans la bouche de paul mc 1 c'est
important pour les lecteurs américains
bien sûr ces choses-là d'intégrité de
sont importantes pour l'acteur américain
donc jeu
je préfère pas me juger là dessus parce
que je pense que si une affaire aussi
grave était avérée elle ne résisterait
pas au comment dirais-je à l'observation
et la vigilance des médias américains
quels qu'ils soient d'ailleurs presse
écrite ou presse audiovisuelle même donc
vous permettra d'être assez prudent sur
ce sujet certainement que ce que les
américains attendent c'est ce que
d'ailleurs ce que monsieur byden a dit
c'est un retour d'une forme de décence
dans le débat public aux états unis au
delà de cette élection mais aussi
pendant cette élection est donc pendant
ce débat qui pourra être un test aussi
du ton adopté par l'un et l'autre des
candidats qui jusqu'ici ne s'est pas
montré particulièrement favorable pour
monsieur trombe
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté
notre débat en direct sur arte france
merci à vous et yannick mireur
politologue spécialiste des états unis
merci à vous paul rinne président de
république m
in france